hallo und willkommen zu ZDF heute live
schön dass ihr bei uns seid in
Johannesburg treffen sich die
bricks-staaten bricks das bedeutet
Brasilien Russland Indien China und
Südafrika hier sehen wir die Staatschefs
aus einigen der Länder und für Moskau
ist Außenminister lavroff da ja die
Frage ist warum ist das so spannend
warum reden wir heute Abend über dieses
Treffen weil es im Prinzip um den Wunsch
nach einer anderen Weltordnung geht und
damit um die Frage entmachten die
brix-staaten den Westen darüber sprechen
wir gleich mit der
Politikwissenschaftlerin Miriam Chris
Hansen vom Forschungsinstitut Giga
schreibt uns eure Fragen und Kommentare
ihr wisst Bescheid einfach in die Chats
posten oder eine E-Mail schicken jetzt
starten wir erstmal in Südafrika in
Johannesburg mit unserem Reporter Jan
fritzsche
hallo Jan guten Abend
lass uns vielleicht direkt am Anfang die
Frage klären was wollen denn die bricks
starken grundsätzlich
starten wollen erstmal ihren
Machteinfluss erweitern also sie stehen
im Moment jetzt für etwas mehr als 40
Prozent der Weltbevölkerung und rund ein
Viertel der Weltwirtschaft und sie haben
schon große Ziele also sie wollen
sozusagen den Westen ablösen als die
dominierende Kraft in der Weltordnung
das heißt das ist schon sehr
ambitioniert aber es ist auch schwer von
den brick-staaten zu sprechen als als
als Blog weil sie sind teilweise auch
sehr zerstritten also China und Russland
zum Beispiel haben durchaus andere
Interessen wollen durchaus mächtig
werden ein großes ein großes
Gegengewicht bilden zum Beispiel zu den
USA indien hat etwas andere Interessen
Indien versucht eher auf
Wirtschaftswachstum zu setzen und mit
verschiedenen Partnern zu Recht zu
kommen also da sieht man schon erste
Unterschiede bei diesen brix-staaten
über diesen Punkt dass die durchaus
unterschiedliche Ziele haben darüber
werden wir später noch sprechen jetzt
dauert dieses Treffen ja drei Tage was
es heute am ersten Tag passiert
ja es ging erstmal heute morgen los hat
es einen Staatsempfang gegeben der
Staatspräsident hier von Südafrika hat
den chinesischen Staatspräsidenten
Archie empfangen da wurden 25 Jahre
Beziehungen gefeiert und es ging vor
allem um Wirtschaft also die beiden
haben da intensiv wirklich noch mal
gesagt dass sie ihren wirtschaftlichen
Austausch intensivieren wollen und dass
es so ein bisschen das große Thema das
sowohl bei diesem Treffen als auch dann
später die Wirtschaft im Vordergrund
stand heute Abend haben sich dann
mehrere Staatschef der brix-staaten
getroffen also von Brasilien konkret
auch von Indien und von Südafrika
nochmal und haben sich noch mal über das
Thema Wirtschaft unterhalten ist also
die globale Wirtschaftsordnung
transformiert werden müsste die
Interessen der sich entwickelnden Länder
stärker berücksichtigen müsste das heißt
das war schon mal ein klarer Fokus des
heutigen Tages dieses Wirtschaftsthema
und was ist generell das Ziel dieses
Treffens allgemein was soll in den
nächsten drei Tagen dann noch passieren
es gibt im Prinzip zwei große Themen
also das eine Thema ist eine mögliche
Erweiterung der bricks-staaten sind der
bisher fünf Staaten die bricks sagen
dass sie bereits 23 formale Anträge
hätten von einer anderen Staaten die
Mitglieder werden wollen das sind zum
Beispiel Staaten wie Iran Ägypten oder
auch Saudi-Arabien das heißt das ist
eine Frage über die ist auch Streit gibt
um die gerungen wird diese Erweiterung
und auf der anderen Seite geht es eben
vor allem um wirtschaftliche Fragen des
Stichwort hier ist die sogenannte die
dollarization wie es auf Englisch heißt
also quasi den Dollar den US-Dollar zu
schwächen da wird sogar davon gesprochen
ob die bridgestanden sogar eine eigene
Währung etablieren könnten in der sie
untereinander Handel betreiben so weit
es ist aber bisher noch nicht bisher ist
es so dass Sie versuchen wirklich in
ihren eigenen Währungen in ihren eigenen
landesführung stärker untereinander
Handel zu treiben und so ein
Gegengewicht auch zum Dollar zu bilden
auf Youtube er fragt wie viele Staaten
wollen denn genau bei Brix beitreten
welche sind denn z.B runter
genau also es gibt es heißt dass es mehr
als 40 Interessenten insgesamt gibt
einen konkreten Antrag sondern die
bricks Start gesagt haben eben 23
Staaten gestellt ich habe schon kurz
erwähnt also Iran Saudi-Arabien zum
Beispiel und ist es durchaus interessant
weil Saudi-Arabien ja zum Beispiel noch
vor kurzem auch als ein starker
Verbündeter zum Beispiel der USA galt
und sich eher dem Westen zugeneigt hat
und das jetzt offenbar ein Land wie
Saudi-Arabien großes Interesse hat sich
diesen bricks Bündnis zuzuwenden das
spricht schon auch für den steigenden
Einfluss dieser Länder jetzt ist es ja
so dass einer fehlt und das ist der
russische Präsident Putin eben weil er
mit internationalem Strafbefehl gesucht
wird Jan da hatte die südafrikanische
Regierung ja relativ lange gezögert bis
sie sich in dieser Frage ob er anreisen
kann und unter welchen Voraussetzungen
und mit welchen Konsequenzen bis ich die
Regierung da positioniert hatte
ja es gab da ein großes hin und her das
ging monatelang kommt Putin jetzt her zu
diesem Gipfel oder kommt er nicht her
für Südafrikas ist es eine schwierige
Position weil Südafrika zum einen den
Krieg in der Ukraine nicht klar
verurteilt hat und auch historisch
gewachsene Beziehung zu Russland hat
also im Kampf gegen die Apartheid hier
im Land gibt es eine große Zuneigung in
Teilen der Bevölkerung in Teilen der
politischen Klasse zu Russland deswegen
wollte man Russland nicht verprellen
aber auf der anderen Seite ist Südafrika
eben auch an die Statuten des
Strafgerichtshofs gebunden und hätte
Putin wohl verhaften müssen das heißt
für das Land war es ein Dilemma am Ende
ist es dann so gekommen dass es wohl
Gespräche gehabt zwischen Russland und
Südafrika und dann die russische Seite
gesagt hat dass sie dann eben auf einen
Besuch hier von Putin verzichten
lass uns bei dem Punkt kurz bleiben und
unseren Moskau am Körper dazu holen
und da ist er hallo an grüße Dich
ein Präsident der dann doch lieber im
Land bleibt weil er seine Festnahme
fürchten muss wie kommt das an
also dass der Präsident des größten
Landes der Welt nicht zu diesem Gipfel
reisen kann weil ihm dort die Festnahme
droht das ist natürlich eine riesige
Blamage und das kann auch keiner hier
schön reden das ist interessant Putin
hat das begründet offiziell damit seine
Präsenz in Moskau in Russland sei in
diesen Tagen einfach wichtiger als seine
Gegenwart auf dem Gipfel in in Südafrika
aber es ist interessant zu sehen er hat
ähm wie zur Untermalung dessen sich
während seine vor aufgezeichnete
Videobotschaft ausgestrahlt wurde und
auch während die meisten anderen ihre
Reden hielten hat er sich demonstrativ
hinter mir im kremme mit den Vertretern
des Rates für strategische Planung
getroffen das heißt man kann das wohl
interpretieren als Reaktion darauf dass
er eben physisch auch nicht an dem
Gipfel teilnehmen kann aber solche
Gipfel treffen Leben doch auch davon
dass dann mal zwischen den offiziellen
Terminen deal gemacht werden kann außen
eine salafrauf der jetzt für ihn in
Johannesburg ist kann er ihn da hat der
Quad ersetzen
ist natürlich einer der erfahrensten und
härtesten Verhandler gegenwärtig der
Weltpolitik der Mann ist seit knapp 20
Jahren im Amt der ist natürlich salopp
gesagt mit allen Wassern gewaschen
gleichzeitig ist es so wie du schon
gesagt hast es geht ja um Kontakte es
geht darum miteinander zu reden beim
Essen und so weiter da kann er den
Präsidenten natürlich nicht ersetzen und
es geht auch ganz protokollarisch darum
dem z.B dem chinesischen Präsidenten
Tschechien Ping kann sehr gelabroff als
Außenminister nicht so gegenübertreten
und begegnen wie das Präsident Putin
könnte insbesondere weil die beiden ja
sowas wie eine Freundschaft verbindet
die treffen sich ja extrem häufig also
gibt es schon ein riesen Unterschied ob
man persönlich oder in diesem Fall
Präsident Putin persönlich vor Ort ist
oder eben sich per Video schaltet zu
Wort meldet wie er das vorhin gemacht
hat was hat er gesagt was will was
braucht er von den bricks starten
der hat über eine Stunde verspätet seine
Rede begonnen die ging ungefähr 17
Minuten er hat noch einmal betont die
Sanktionen des Westens gegen sein Land
sein
illegal und Design verantwortlich für
den Hunger in der Welt er hat Bezug
genommen auf das gescheiterte
getreideabkommen da ging es ja darum
Wege zu finden wie das Getreide aus der
Ukraine exportiert werden kann
insbesondere in die ärmeren Länder z.B
in Afrika da behauptet er jetzt dass er
alles Lüge er hätte den gibt dieses
dieses Abkommen nicht platzen lassen und
im übrigen würde dieses Getreide auch
überhaupt nicht an die Länder Afrikas
geliefert oder kaum Alter spricht davon
einem Prozent erfordert eine
Weltwirtschaft auf Augenhöhe freien
handelt das Recht aller ländert auch
wirtschaftliche Entwicklung und ähm es
ist natürlich dahinter steht für ihn der
die die Notwendigkeit Russland braucht
dringend neue
Importe neue Handelspartner auch um den
der Fall der Landeswährung Rubel hier
aufzuhalten er braucht dringend
Rohstoffe und Komponente weil ja aus dem
besten sehr viel weniger oder fast
nichts mehr geliefert wird er muss die
Rüstungsindustrie am Laufen halten auch
andere Branchen leiden darunter das kaum
Komponenten und Rohstoffe ins Land
kommen das heißt dieser Gipfel ist für
ihn sehr wichtig und ist dieser Gipfel
insofern für ihn auch wichtig kann man
sagen um eben zu zeigen Russland ist
nicht isoliert in der Welt
genau das wird natürlich rauf und runter
hier betont die Botschaft das Russland
zu diesem Club gehört je größer der ist
desto besser das sind natürlich das ist
ja klar nachvollziehbar er will ein
Gegengewicht bilden er will auch
geostrategisch klar machen es gibt ein
Gegengewicht zu den USA diese Länder
halten zusammen ist ein offener Club
gerecht auf Augenhöhe und so weiter er
betont ja immer wieder das hat er auch
heute wieder getan seine Vision von
einer neuen Weltordnung in der jedes
Land das Recht hat seine eigenen
Interessen zu vertreten seine Kultur und
Geschichte auszuleben und dabei immer
auf die Unterstützung Russland zählen
kann
ja vielleicht noch mal zu dir generell
welche Rolle spielt der Krieg in der
Ukraine bei diesem Treffen
durchaus schon eine große Rolle weil er
Russlands Interesse an diesem bricks
Bündnis deutlich verstärkt hat man hat
zwischendurch schon gedacht noch vor ein
paar Jahren dass vielleicht dieses
bricksbündnis hier eine schlechte Idee
ist gar keinen großen Einfluss hat aber
jetzt dadurch dass Russland ebenso
isoliert ist
international auch mit dem Westen immer
weniger Handel betreiben kann durch die
Sanktionen das für Russland enorm
wichtig geworden um zum Beispiel
Rohstoffe zu verkaufen und deswegen
spielt das hier schon eine enorme Rolle
und das hat das Interesse von Russland
dieses glücksbündnis wirklich nach vorne
zu treiben auch noch mal deutlich erhöht
es gibt noch eine andere Frage auf
Youtube sind die anderen Präsidenten
anwesend gewesen oder hat noch jemand
gefehlt ja
naja wir haben heute zumindest erstmal
diesen Staatsbesuch gesehen von Rama
Posa und von Archie aus China das heißt
wir haben schon mal zwei gesehen und
dann heute Abend bei dem
Wirtschaftsforum haben wir den indischen
Staatspräsidenten gesehen auch den aus
Brasilien auch da noch mal Pose aus
Südafrika das heißt es haben sich
zumindest heute vier der fünf schon mal
gezeigt und Putin ist ja eben wie wir
gehört haben in Russland geblieben ja
und noch eine letzte Frage Russland
möchte ja z.B das bricks größer wird
Indien ist zum Beispiel dagegen warum
gibt es in diesem Punkt keine Einigkeit
ja also sind vor allem China und
Russland die da treibende Kräfte sind
die auf der gleichen Seite stehen und
die sagen wir müssen möglichst groß
diesen bricks Club Club machen um eben
möglichst viel Einfluss zu haben als
auch als Gegengewicht zu den USA die
anderen Länder sind da deutlich
reserviertierter also Indien zum
Beispiel das auch westliche
Handelspartner hat und darauf sehr
großen Wert legt und das auch verhindern
möchte dass China wirklich zu dieser
großen internationalen Vormachtstellung
kommt die dann vielleicht nicht mehr
einholbar ist also deswegen sind die
Interessen da sehr unterschiedlich
gelagert und es ist zwar ein Club der
sich zusammenschließt auch viel Handel
betreiben will der aber nicht von der
großen Ideologie zusammengehalten wird
sondern vor allem wenn das eigene
fortkommendenkt und da sind eben die
Interessen teilweise sehr sehr
unterschiedlich
lieber Jan in Johannesburg lieber Armin
in Moskau vielen Dank für Ihre
Informationen und Einschätzungen macht's
gut tschüss
ja und damit gehen wir direkt weiter zur
Politikwissenschaftlerin Miriam pries
Hansen vorher fast und Sarah saska noch
mal die allerwichtigsten Infos zu diesem
Treffen zusammen
sie sind fünf aufstrebende
Volkswirtschaften die Prix starten
bricks das steht für Brasilien Russland
Indien China und Südafrika gemeinsam
machen sie etwa 40 Prozent der
Weltbevölkerung aus und ein Viertel der
globalen Wirtschaftsleistung zum
Vergleich die G7 Staaten zu denen auch
Deutschland gehört vertreten rund ein
Zehntel der globalen Bevölkerung und
rund 44% der weltweiten
Wirtschaftsleistung die brix-gruppe
wurde 2009 gegründet damals noch ohne
Südafrika das Land kam 2011 hinzu
bislang galt die Gruppe als Loser er
symbolischer Zusammenschluss ungleicher
Nationen ein wirtschaftszweckbündnis mit
wenig Gewicht bei den jährlichen
Gipfeltreffen ging es meist um engere
wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit und
Klimaschutz jetzt soll alles anders
werden sie wollen mächtiger sein mehr
Gewicht auf der weltpolitischen Bühne
haben ein Gegenentwurf zu den westlichen
G7 sein und der wirtschaftliche
Aufschwung macht die brix-gruppe
attraktiver denn je über 40 Staaten
möchten den Bündnis beitreten mehr als
20 haben einen Beitritt bereits formal
beantragt darunter Saudi-Arabien Ägypten
und Iran
guten Abend Frau pressanzen guten Abend
warum ist diese Gruppe aktuell für so
viele Länder interessant
naja da gibt es es wurde auch gerade die
Unterschiede wurden ja gerade auch schon
ganz gut beleuchtet
unterschiedliche Länder haben
unterschiedliche Ansprüche also
beispielsweise in Landwehr Argentinien
sucht insbesondere den Zugang zum
chinesischen Markt Länder wie Iran oder
Venezuela sehen bricks als eine
Möglichkeit eben westliche Sanktionen zu
vermeiden oder zu umgehen also da so so
divers die bricks sind so divers sind
auch die die Ansprüche und die
Vorstellungen der möglichen
Beitrittskandidaten was sie eben von den
bricks bekommen können um gemeinsames
Symbol ist natürlich die ja wie schon
gesagt die Symbolkraft eines
Zusammenschluss zu globalen Südens der
steht natürlich das haben sie alle
gemeinsam Unterschieden
wir haben es eben schon gehört da gibt
es eben keine Einigkeit in der Frage der
Erweiterung was ist ihre Einschätzung
Wörter die besseren Chancen sich
durchzusetzen
ich denke da ist die würde ich sagen die
verzögerungsmöglichkeiten von Indien und
Brasilien werden da vermutlich Überwegen
also es werden jetzt auch auch durch
Südafrika was eher so eine
Mittelposition einnimmt
gibt so eine Rhetorik wie sagt naja wir
müssen uns erstmal über die
Beitrittskriterien
einigen und da hat ja auch der der
Kollege schon gesagt dass was fehlt ist
so eine gemeinsame Identität dieser
Staaten und dann ist es natürlich auch
schwierig zu entscheiden wer gehört denn
zu uns und wer nicht und ich denke das
wird längere Diskussionen nach sich
ziehen und davon profitieren natürlich
die Länder die da eher zögerlich sind
also
zumeist Indien und was sie ihren hier
gibt's noch mal eine Frage von smile er
schreibt auf Youtube kein drecks Land
verurteilt den Angriffskrieg auf die
Ukraine inwiefern spielt das eine Rolle
na das ist natürlich weltpolitisch schon
wichtig also Südafrika und hat hat gegen
wichtige un Sanktionen gestimmt China
und Indien haben sich enthalten und das
sind natürlich schon Gewichte die auch
signalisieren an andere Länder das ist
in Ordnung so was zu machen
und ich glaube aber nicht dass die der
der Gipfel an sich drumherum kommen wird
die Frage zu diskutieren allerdings
würde wäre ich sehr überrascht wenn es
irgendwie eine eindeutige Positionierung
gibt ähm gegen den Krieg ich denke das
Motto wird sein nicht alliiert bedeutet
nicht neutral Werte müssen aufrecht
erhalten werden der Frieden soll wieder
hergestellt werden aber eine ganz
eindeutige Verurteilung wird es
sicherlich nicht geben
schreibt das Facebook warum sind die
demokratischen Staaten innerhalb des
bricks so sehr distanziert gegenüber den
USA dass sie verstärkt mit China und
Russland zusammenarbeiten wollen
na dass das distanziert würde ich gar
nicht so sehen also insbesondere
Südafrika was immer was traditionell
eher skeptisch auch gegenüber den USA
ist sucht im Moment ganz stark wieder
die Partnerschaft
genauso Indien indien hat jetzt kürzlich
mit den
Premierminister Modi war erst der zweite
wenn ich mich recht erinnere Staatschef
der überhaupt zweimal schon bereits vor
dem US-Kongress gesprochen hat es wurden
wichtige technologieabkommen
abgeschlossen also ich glaube nicht dass
das eine Entscheidung gegen den Westen
ist ganz und gar nicht also das würde
weder Indien weder Brasilien und auch
Südafrika so sicherlich nicht
unterschreiben Indien da kenne ich mich
persönlich am besten aus fährt sehr gut
mit diesem sowohl als auch und ich
glaube
dass das in gewisser Weise auch ne
gerechtfertig und ganz klar im Interesse
dieser Staaten auch es sich nicht
entscheiden zu müssen
Norbert Kranz geht normal auf diese
Uneinigkeiten ein er sagt die bricks die
haben noch gar keinen gemeinsames Werte
Korsett wie soll das denn zusammenpassen
im Gegensatz dazu seien sich die sieben
noch einig
ja das ist sicherlich eine richtige
Feststellung allerdings
[Musik]
gibt es ja schon Einigkeit in der
wirklich wichtigen Frage zu sagen
internationale Institutionen wie die
Vereinten Nationen wie die Weltbank
wieder Internationale Währungsfonds
müssen gerechter und
repräsentativer werden und diese dieser
politische Säule der bricks ist schon
wichtig und hat Großes Symbolkraft
ja genau und ich glaube da sind sich
demokratische und nicht demokratische
Staaten auch auch einig in diesem Fall
natürlich gibt es unterhalb dieser Decke
sehr viele Streitigkeiten auch
hier gibt's noch mal eine Nachfrage zur
Rolle Indiens die sie eben erläutert
haben da schreibt's mal in den geht mit
seinen Beziehungen zum Westen und auch
mit dem Engagement bei Brix ja einen
großen geopolitischen Spagat ob der auf
Dauer gelingen kann
also mal kurze Antwort ja als ich denke
Indien ist groß genug mittlerweile und
hat ausreichend Ressourcen auch für sich
und Attraktivität dass der Spagat glaube
ich sehr gut gelingen würde Indien
schafft das sowas wie eine neue Art der
Außenpolitik die sich eben
zeigt genau in diesem sowohl als auch
und ich glaube damit werden wir leben
müssen so
so schwierig das eben dann auch manchmal
ist
schauen wir auf China ist er mit der
größte Player warum engagiert sich China
jetzt so stark bei den brexit
also zu Anfang waren die bricks für
China man sagte so China ist heiding
behind the bricks also das quasi die
eigene Stärke und der eigene Aufschwung
so ein bisschen versteckt wird dass es
nicht so sehr als Bedrohung wahrgenommen
wird diese Katze ist nun sprichwörtlich
aus dem Sack also china ist ein ist die
zweitgrößte Volkswirtschaft und so
weiter von daher würde es jetzt eher für
China ist das ganz wichtig so als
Legitimierung sieht nicht nur wir
kritisieren sondern der komplette
globale Süden idealerweise weil China
ist treibt ja auch diesen
Erweiterungsprozess an ist auch unserer
Seite und so weiter und wir können eben
als Symbol
Symbol macht das eben
Wirtschaftswachstum in ganz
unterschiedlichen politischen Regimen
stattfinden kann zeigen also für China
ist das sehr wichtig als Legitimierung
der eigenen Kraft sozusagen
der bricks Gipfel das Treffen findet ja
in Südafrika statt welche Rolle spielt
Afrika dieser Kontinent generell für
Brixen
ich also Südafrika zeigt sich da sehr
gerne als ähm wir stehen gar nicht nur
für Südafrika sondern wir repräsentieren
ganz Afrika das wird von einigen
afrikanischen Staaten auch recht
kritisch gesehen
aber natürlich hat zum Beispiel die die
Nut Development Bank das ist die
Entwicklungsbank der bricks finanziert
relativ viel Infrastruktur in
afrikanischen Ländern und der Bedarf an
gerade Finanzierung von
Infrastrukturprojekten ist natürlich
weiter hoch in Afrika und da ist
natürlich der Wunsch auch vor allem
chinesische Investitionen indische
Investition anzuziehen und zu
erleichtern über diese bricks
Partnerschaft und auch damit eben den
Einfluss in diesen Regionen zu erweitern
Ivan hat noch eine Frage auf Facebook er
fragt ist es möglich dass nicht
EU-Staaten wie z.B Serbien den
brückstaaten beitreten
also gerade Serbien das halte ich für
recht unwahrscheinlich ich weiß jetzt
gar nicht ob Serbien informellen
Beitrittsantrag gestellt hat das wäre
mir jetzt nicht bekannt aber ich glaube
das ist insgesamt für kleine Staaten
eher schwierig wird da das natürlich je
mehr Staaten dabei sind und in dieser
informellen Institution die bricks ja
ist müssen ja alle immer zu einem
zustimmen deswegen glaube ich dass
gerade Indien Brasilien und vermutlich
auch die anderen erstmal nicht so viel
davon haben wenn jetzt ganz viele kleine
Staaten dazu kommen dass widerspricht
natürlich dann auch so der
Funktionsweise der bricks der heutigen
Funktionsweise der brexit sind etwas von
daher halte ich das jetzt unabhängig von
der geographischen Lage für eher
unwahrscheinlich dass jetzt viele kleine
Staaten
aufgenommen oder engere Partnerschaften
mit den eingegangen werden
ich würde gerne noch mal auf den Titel
unseres Streams zurückkommen dazu
schreibt zum Beispiel Andreas auf
Facebook die Zeit der alten Weststaaten
ist vorbei und dies ist gut so die ähm
unser Titel ist entmachten die
glücksstaaten den Westen ist so
ja das glaube ich nicht vor allem nicht
so schnell ich glaube und ich denke das
ist auch realistisch beispielsweise hat
der südafrikanische Präsident am Sonntag
in seiner Grundsatzrede zur auspolitik
gesagt wir wollen gar niemanden
entmachten wir wollen gar nichts abbauen
wir wollen Alternativen schaffen also
wieder wir sind wieder bei dem nicht bei
dem entweder oder sondern beim sowohl
als auch und ich denke das ist auch
realistisch und vielleicht auch gar
nicht so das schlechteste dass das in
etwas
naja in geregelten Bahnen innerhalb von
so einem von so einem
partnerschaftsforum wieder brexit
funktioniert das jetzt eben nicht China
die ähm die die seine kompletten
Interessen durchsetzen kann sondern dass
das durch Indien und Brasilien etwas
moderiert wird und ich glaube in machten
des Westens steht nicht da was so eine
vielleicht eine eher eine Anhebung der
anderen so dass wir eher über eine
Augenhöhe sprechen können und wie gesagt
darum werden wir nicht drumherum kommen
und ich denke innerhalb der bricks wenn
sie da Gesprächspartner gibt eben aus
den Demokratie auch das dass das so auch
gut Stück für Stück geschafft werden
kann
dazu schreibt Senf auf youtube ist er
eigentlich nicht schlecht wenn auch
Symbiosen Handelsabkommen etc in den
nicht westlichen Systemen entstehen das
erhöht den Wettbewerb wie sehen Sie das
ja natürlich also
man muss natürlich wir haben natürlich
bestimmte Werte hier wie bestimmte
Umwelt es geht fängt los von immer
Normen Menschenrechten und so weiter und
ich denke es sollte schon weiterhin auch
im Interesse Europas sein auch diese
unsere diese Vorstellungen auch weiter
nach außen zu präsentieren aber
unterstelle mich schon zu
natürlich sind wir nicht alle ähm und es
ist wichtig dass es
Teilhabe gibt und wenn die Staaten sich
einfach mächtiger werden ist es auch
wichtig dass man miteinander spricht
weil sonst laufen wir wirklich die
Gefahr dass es zum Wettbewerb im Sinne
von der Konferenz oder Konferenz
Konkurrenz und einem entweder oder wird
die letzte Frage für heute kommt von Not
auf Youtube er fragte mich würde
interessieren wie der Westen dagegen
vorgehen will oder wenn was vielleicht
ein bisschen neutraler formulieren wie
sollte der Westen jetzt auf diese
Entwicklung reagieren
also dagegen vorgehen ich glaube das ist
nicht das wird nicht passieren
aber ich denke dass man sich
insbesondere mit den demokratischen
bricks verständigen sollte eng
zusammenarbeiten sollte und ich denke
gerade im Bereich Indien was ja wirklich
sehr lange vernachlässigt wurde
dass da jetzt auch ganz viel passiert
ich sehe das persönlich zum Beispiel ich
Porsche viel zu Indien ich bekomme sehr
viel mehr Anfragen es besteht sehr viel
mehr Interesse auch was ist denn dieses
Indien eigentlich wie funktioniert das
alles und ich denke das ist eine sehr
gute Entwicklung für globale Kooperation
in so wichtigen Fragen wie Klimawandel
das werden wir nur
schaffen können wenn alle sich fair
behandelt fühlen und eben auch
mitgenommen werden und mit entscheiden
können das machen wir jetzt im Westen
nicht alleine
Frau Präsidenten ich danke Ihnen ganz
herzlich für Ihre Einschätzung machen
sie es gut schönen Abend noch tschüss
vielen Dank danke Ja und damit machen
wir dann auch Schluss für heute ZDF
heute live war das zum Treffen der
bricks starten mach's gut tschüss